welcome to jail directions to Belvoir
Valley Farm and the new owner infimum
air correct I think there's an
intriguing backstory to your arrival
well after losing my job and my
boyfriend in San Francisco I am sitting
in an in contest youth wanted in located
in New Zealand so my 13 hour flights
Auckland and rebus tried later
[Music]
I'm so sorry I will pay for any of the
damages well this did put a big dent in
my there you go ha ha I'm officially the
owner of an imp you never assume
anything when the internet matches this
profile picture you've seen a ghost
built Gilbert he's a wily fella do you
know anybody in town that does
renovation strike Tyler can I have his
phone number
Jake what's your phone number who's
asking she goes no I didn't what do you
want my number I was hoping to talk to
you about a proposition she's a real
beauty I can help you you're still a
hitter original glory
brilliant you see broken what's with you
in the old houses
oh well always took the building makes
me feel a little worse again I believe
Big Town was most eligible bachelor
might be keen on you she's a beaut
she sure is
hey Chad yes guess what I got a brand
new job for you
I do have my realize to get back down on
your real love seems to me you haven't
told her how you actually feel
I'm guessing the universe has its own
plans for things I like to imagine a
very tiny
so we're friends -
[Music]
you